I have to ask you Dan quickly you had a
love scene in the first season a on
estate a sex scene and your father was
on set for it and watching happy is that
with his eyebrows undulating yeah you
can always tell when you're doing a good
or bad job just based on the undulation
of the eyebrows so you had a sex scene
oh yeah we were in bed and you know it
was just one of those I was sort of on
set in the bed and just constantly
asking pas who were running back and
forth is he still here is he still
watching them oh he's still watching
okay did he get it I think we got know
if they'll hear it still why don't you
want to be there for that it's he's a
dance mom right he's sort of standing
watching I'm a brother on the show I
have to be there to watch you know you
could have excused yourself I'm not
saying it wasn't a little there scene
creepy yeah but you know it's kind of an
icky thing when you're watching you know
your kid doing yeah yeah yeah and yeah
it shows to stay which is really great
our secret is this persnickety
restaurants yeah short temper boy love
to watch your kid go at it all right
you
[Applause]
you